*Amusement avec une musique malaisante*
Malaise Malaise arrêtez !
Aujourd'hui on est sur quoi Lucas Hauchard ?
Explique-nous un p'tit peu les gens veulent savoir
On est sur WikiHow on a déjà fait une vidéo dessus
Souvenez-vous, c'est un site dans lequel on a des images comme ça
Tirées du site WikiHow.com à savoir
Comment faire bidule comment faire machin ?
Et on a trouvé la phrase qui correspond. Bref, vous connaissez, vous avez vu la vidéo n°1
Ah tu l'as pas vue ?
Il a pas vu la première vidéo !
Il se br**lait sur les pectoraux de "TiboInShape" au lieu de la regarder !
Ok, première image. Ouuuuuuu !
Comment pécho un mec en faisant l'expression de la meuf qui veut pécho un mec mais qui n'y arrive pas ?
C'est trop long. Nan tu ne clique pas sur le pectoraux "TiboInShape" !
Comment faire comme Bella dans Twilight? C'est ça c'est sûr.
Oh Put*in!! Oh j'ai même pas lu les autres! On arrive d'entrée de jeu on est dans le game!
Y a vraiment un tuto pour faire comme Bella... de Twilight...
Est qu'il y a un tuto pour faire comme Squeezie de la chaîne Squeezie?
*Générique C'est pas Sorcier *
Mangez le moins possible et faite vraiment très peu de sport!
En quelques jours vous aurez...
UN BON CORPS NUL!
Ok suivant..
Comment effleurer la main d'un gobelin...
C'est pas ça?
Nan sans déconner mec... c'est quoi cette main?
* Musique érotique *
NON...
Alors comment... Comment agir comme sonic.. l'hérisson.
Comment accepter l'interêt de ton copain pour la pornographie
Nan je pense que c'est... Bah c'est sonic! Bah clairement...
Bah oui bah oui...
Ah non c'est comment accepter le fait que ton copain mate du porno!
Bah tout le monde va effacer son historique c'est bon! ça passe tout seul après...
Ooooooooouuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuhhhhhhh...
Comment faire des ombres chinoises!
On connais, on connais! FAITES PAS GENRE! C'est le loup!
Comment traiter une infection nasale naturellement?
Comment être une hipster?
Comment arrêter de penser qu'accepter de l'aide est un signe de faiblesse?
Et la dernière j'ai la flemme de la lire... *rire de fdp*
C'est comment être une hipster...
Quoi...?
Comment arrêter de penser qu'accepter de l'aide est un signe de faiblesse
Faut arrêter d'être con!
C'est parce que tu m'aides en regardant mes vidéos que suis faible!
Bon chui un mauvais exemple...
Comment... faire un dessin... sans trop se faire chier
C'est ça!
Nan? ça je suis capable de le faire...
* Musique épique digne des films les plus épique de toute l'histoire de l'art épique. épique. *
Ooooooh! eh! c'est le meilleur dessin que j'ai fait ces quatre dernières années!
Je vais appeler ma mère putain...
Elle va être tellement émue...
Biiiip... Biiiip...
Mme Hauchard : Allô!
Squeezie: Allô maman!
Mme Hauchard: Oui?
Squeezie : Je viens de faire un dessin magnifique!
BIGGEST PUNCHLINE DU SIECLE DANS: 3... 2... 1...
C'est intéressant
Bip Bip Bip
J'ai toujours préféré papa !
Ah celui-là je l'ai, Ah celui-là je l'ai mec !
Ah non j'lai pas !
Commen.. Ha Ha
Comment survivre quand tu fais pas assez de vue ! Ha HA
Bah c'est comment être un Successful Teenager c'est sûr !
Bah OUI !
Le gars il réussi ses études mais en même temps il est en.. en 50 heures à Monoprix chaques semaines
Il a trop de talent !
Y nous énerve ce mec !
Bon après il réussit mais dans son regard on dirait quand même qu'y a une petite envie deeuuu... mettre fin à sa vie !
" Mais je veux être chirurgien pourquoi je me retrouve à ranger des bananes dans des sacs ?! "
" Et pourquoi je n'ai que quatre doigts ? "
" Rroo je pourrais jamais être chirurgien finalement ! "
OOKKK !
Comment monter une photo de trou du c*l mais en gardant le sourire ?!
Oh c'est mature ça !
Comment perdre ta virginité mais sans douleur
On est pas loin du coup !
C'est le trou d'à côté !
OOOOOHHHHH !!! *Musique d'ambiance*
NNAAANN
Qu'est-ce qui se passe sur la chaîne de Squeezie ?
Ça mérite de s'infliger une punition tout ça !
Comment faire un enfant ?
C'est ça nan ?
Ah non c'était bien comment perdre sa virginité sans douleur !
Mais qu'est-ce... Ça illustre quoi ?
*Musique érotique*
On veut pas savoir !
Comment s'enfuir face à Fantominus ?
*Petit rire*
Ça vous a pas fait rire ?!
Comment être moins collant
Comment s'apprécier
Ou comment rester calme à propos d'une ex
Eeeuuuuhh...
Comment s'aimer !
Et oui !
Bah je sais bien comment faire vu que je me kiffe
Comment ne plus être schizophrène sur les chiottes
Nan ?
Comment arrêter son addiction à la masturbation
Bah c'est ça !
*Rire*
*Petite musique d'ambiance*
Comment ne pas entendre les haineux !
OOOOOOOHHHHHH !!!
Ho Ha Ha !
Oh elle est bien celle là !
Comment... plagier monstres et compagnie
*Rire*
Ah l'truc il a un œil il est vert ça y est  c'est du plagiat Bravo Squeezie !
Conna*d !
*Rire*
Comment mettre du talc sur le gros c*l de ton bébé obèse
Euh non pour de vrai c'est quoi ?
Une gomme ?
Nan mais ça peut pas être comment comprendre les hétéro ?!
Si !
J'ai envie d'y croire !
Oh non !
*Rire* Rrrooo Put*in *Rire*
Là on peut faire du lourd !
On peut faire du très très lourd !
Comment contrer la mauvaise haleine
Oh c'est drôle arrêtez !
Nan là vous êtes méchants !
Là vous faîtes exprès de me laisser bider pour pouvoir vous moquer
Ah je connais bien cette petite stratégie de FDP là hein !
Comment impressionner un collègue de classe ?
Ouuii !
Elle est impressionnée en tout cas !
Comment pécho une collègue de classe c'est pas comme ça hein !
Et tu me fermeras tes narines garçon
Comment... Euh... Se débarrasser du botox !
Bah c'est vrai !
Elle a aucune ride la meuf
Elle a même perdu une narine !
C'est chaud quand même !
Comment refuser un bisou
*Rire*
Oh le manque de respect total !
Valérie, embrasse moi
Comment faire voler des préservatifs
*Rire*
Ah ça parle que de c*l là !
Non pour de vrai !
Comment impressionner les gens
Bah c'est vrai que faire voler des capotes mec c'est impressionnant !
Comment mettre un doigt à une voiture
*Rire*
*Petite musique d'ambiance*
Put*in on s'arrête plus !
Vous avez vu vous êtes abonné à un bof
Vous êtes abonné à un gros bof !
How to deal with a love triangle
Oh c'est drôle ça
Oh put*in
J'aurais dit le mec amoureux de la voiture
La voiture amoureuse de la meuf
La meuf amoureuse du mec
Oh c’était chiant ces explications en plus personne n'a rien compris
*Rire moqueur*
C'est improbable !
Comment choper des filles à l'université
Bah oui !
Tu te colles à son dos comme ça
Et tu fais tourner une balle sur ton doigt mon gars !
Ça fait craquer toutes les filles
Arrête
Comment tout tenter pour pécho une fille
Pour tenir la main de Sarah
J'ai du m'enfoncer deux cotons tiges très profond dans le nez et loucher
Depuis
Je n'ai plus de dignité
Comment devenir un hacker
C'est ça mec c'est sûr !
NOPE
*Rire*
Ça m'aurait fait rire ! Ça m'aurait fait rire !
Ahhh !
Qu'est-ce que ça peut être *Rire*
Rencontrer une porn star dans ta zo.. dans ton... dans ta ville
Ça me fait bégayer carrément !
Comment arrêter son addiction à la masturbation
Comment se garer
Euh bon bah on va rencontrer une porn star
Nan !?
Comment se garer What the F*ck ?
Ah non j'ai oublié un L
Gargle ça veut dire quoi ?
Se gargariser
Ah oui c'est quand tu fais *bruit* avec de l'eau
Ça me semble plus logique
Que de se garer
A moins que la meuf elle adore vraiment les voitures
Et quand tu gares sa voiture elle...
*Petite musique d'ambiance*
Comment se nourrir quand t'as plus à manger chez toi *Rire*
Parce qu'il mange ses doigts
Oh c'est nul !
Tiens j'enchaîne tellement les bides ça me donne chaud
Comment se sentir bien dans sa peau c'est ça ?
Quoi ?
Comment reconnaitre les signes avant de devenir abusif
D'accord
Alors ça !
Comment faire miniature comme un Youtubeur
Regarde là tu met la tête de Norman
Et là le titre de la vidéo c'est...
Comment rire à une blague de Squeezie ?
Là on est bien
Comment faire des bonnes coquillettes sa mère
Voilà
Quoi ?!
Comment devenir connu sur Youtube ?!
Put*in !
Mais fallait le dire avant mec !
Mais ça fait 900 vidéos qu'on fait là où j'ai ni casserole ni poêle !
C'est pour ça que je bide mon gars !
*Gros rire*
As-tu vu ?
As-tu vu ce à quoi elle pense ?!
Aller on la fait
Comment contrôler son addiction au fistage !
Et BOOM On a gagné le concours du plus gros bof de l'année !
Et bien voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo j'espère que ça vous a plu
Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à l'aimer comme d'habitude
A cliquer, cliquer, cliquer,*Bafouille* cliquer !
Pardon j'ai pas eu ma dose de like hier je suis pas content !
Oh put*in on s'en souviendra pas
Voilà j'avais dit que je ferai une deuxième vidéo sur ce jeu
C'est chose faite
J'espère que ça vous a fait marrer !
Moi Put*in je me..me suis éclaté
En fait
Ne pas regarder les propositions du site mais juste se faire des idées sur quel est le titre de l'article
C'est beaucoup plus marrant !
Enfin c'est mon avis !
J'espère que vous partagez le même avis parce que sinon ça veut dire que vous avez pas trop rit !
Auquel cas euh...
Euh....
Abonnez-Vous !
Voilà ça c'est la répartie d'un Youtubeur en 2016
Aller les amis on se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine vidéo
Merci d'avoir regardé comme à chaque fois
J'espère que vous vous portez bien !
Si c'est pas le cas prend un petit peu de ma pipe en plastique t'as vu !
A très vite là-dedans !
Tchao tout le monde !
Peace